vamos a hacer más ejemplos usando
decimales digamos que queremos sumar 4 y
22 centésimos más 61 punto 37 centésimos
como siempre los animo a pausar el vídeo
ya tratar de resolverlo por ustedes
mismos
bueno la manera en que mi cerebro aborda
este problema es diciendo muy bien tengo
4.22 centésimos + 60 y 1.30 y 7
centésimos así que voy a sumar 4 más 61
461 y por separado voy a sumar 22
centésimas más 37 centésimas más 22
centésimos más 37 centésimas y 4 61 va a
ser igual a 65 y luego 22 centésimas más
37 centésimas bueno cuánto es 22 más 37
20 más 30 es igual a 50
y luego 27 es igual a 9 así que esto es
igual a 59 centésimos
entonces 65 más 59 centésimos lo podemos
escribir como 65 puntos 59 centésimos
como lo dijimos en vídeos anteriores hay
muchas maneras de sumar decimales y en
futuros vídeos vamos a ver algunas
maneras más rápidas de hacer esto pero
quiero enseñarles varias formas y esta
es la manera en que lo hago en mi cabeza
si algo cuesta 61 pesos y 37 centavos y
tengo que pagar un impuesto de 4 pesos y
22 centavos cuánto tengo que pagar en
total esta es la manera en que lo
resuelvo 65 pesos y 59 centavos vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo digamos que tenemos
3.53 centésimos + 4.72 centésimos pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo como
lo hice en el ejemplo anterior podemos
sumar las unidades 3 unidades más 4
unidades
34 y luego sumamos los centésimos 53
centésimos más 72 centésimas más 53
centésimos más 72 centésimas ahora 3 más
4 es bastante sencillo esto es igual a 7
pero cuánto es 53 centésimas más 72
centésimos bueno cuánto es de 53 más 72
lo voy a escribir de esta manera 53
centésimas
+ 72 centésimas
312 5 y luego 50 más 70 es igual a 120
así que esto es igual a 125 centésimos y
como escribimos 125 centésimas en forma
decimal o como un simple número bueno
hay un par de formas para hacer esto
podríamos verlo como 100 centésimos
+ 25 centésimos
y la razón por la que escogí a escribí
100 centésimos es porque esto es igual a
un entero entonces si en centésimos es
igual a 1 más 25 centésimos
recuerden que estoy sumando esto a 7 + 1
+ 25 centésimos así que cuando sumamos
53 centésimos más 72 centésimos
obtenemos 125 centésimos que es lo mismo
que 1 más 25 centésimos ahora el 1 que
es una unidad lo podemos sumar a las
otras unidades
así que siete más uno es igual a 8 y 25
centésimos 8.25 ahora les voy a ayudar a
abordar esto de manera más sistemática y
quiero que piensen que esto es lo mismo
que hicimos y van a escuchar que se dice
que debemos alinear los decimales 3.53
mas 4.72 y la razón de esto es que
tienes que sumar en el lugar correcto
vamos a sumar en la posición correcta
que es básicamente lo que ya hicimos no
lo hicimos organizando lo de esta manera
pero el objetivo es que entiendan lo que
realmente está pasando y entonces
podemos decir 3 centésimos más docentes
imos estoy sumando en la posición de los
centésimos tres más dos es igual a cinco
centésimos y luego tenemos cincuenta
centésimos más setenta centésimos o
también lo podemos ver como cinco
décimos más siete décimos y esto es
igual a doce décimos pero no podemos
escribir doce décimos en la posición de
los décimos 57 es igual a 12 pero esto
es lo mismo que una unidad más dos
décimos
así que escribimos dos décimos en la
posición de los décimos y ponemos uno en
la posición de las unidades así que
cinco décimos más siete décimos es igual
a uno más dos décimos y ahora podemos
sumar las unidades y sumamos uno
+ 34 que es igual a 88 y 2 decimos y 5
centésimos 18 y 25 centésimos y 8.25 el
resultado es el mismo no importa la
forma que decidas abordarlo y esto tiene
sentido estamos sumando centésimas con
centésimos decimos con décimos y
unidades con unidades y cuando sumas te
decimos más décimos y el resultado es
mayor que 1 bueno esa parte que es mayor
que un entero la podemos poner en la
posición de las unidades vamos a
practicar esto en futuros vídeos